[موسيقى]
هذه الازمه بدات عندما ازيحت حكومتي
بمؤامره واستلم السلطه اشخاص يفتقدون الى
الصدقيه 60% من مجلس الوزراء كان خارجا
بكفاله بقضايا فساد عندما فرضت حكومتهم
علينا في ذلك الوقت بدات الازمه وقد
ازدادت سوءا يوما بعد اخر لانهم اساءوا
اداره الاقتصاد واتخذوا خيارات خاطئه ولم
يكونوا مستعدين بالمقارنه مع وضع الاقتصاد
في شهر مارس من العام الفائت عندما كنت
رئيسا للوزراء نجد ان صندوق النقد الدولي
امتدح اقتصاد باكستان وقال اننا نسير في
اتجاه نمو مستدام ومنذ رحيل حكومتنا في
شهر ابريل والاقتصاد يتراجع
[موسيقى]
المواجهات سبق ان حدثت فقد جاءت الشرطه
لمهاجمه منزلي من ثلاث جهات الاف عناصر
الشرطه شاركوا في العمليه ولم يحدث اي شيء
من هذا القبيل في تاريخ بلادنا لماذا
جاؤوا الى منزلي لانهم ارادوا تقديم الى
محكمه اسلام اباد في الثامن عشر من الشهر
الحالي جاءوا في الرابع عشر من مارس
لاعتقالي من اجل المثول امام المحكمه بحسب
مزاعمهم مع انني كنت سامثل في الموعد
المحدد والقانون ينص على ان الشخص الذي
يقدم سند ضمان يؤكد حضوره الى المحكمه في
الموعد المحدد فلا يحك للشرطه اعتقاله
[موسيقى]